In the next section we're going to start our
discussion on how to actually engineer the
bit encodings we'll use in our circuitry,
but first we'll need a way to evaluate the
efficacy of an encoding.
The entropy of a random variable is average
amount of information received when learning
the value of the random variable.
The mathematician's name for "average" is
"expected value"; that's what the capital
E means.
We compute the average in the obvious way:
we take the weighted sum, where the amount
of information received when learning of particular
choice i -- that's the log-base-2 of 1/p_i
-- is weighted by the probability of that
choice actually happening.
Here's an example.
We have a random variable that can take on
one of four values: A, B, C or D.
The probabilities of each choice are shown
in the table, along with the associated information
content.
Now we'll compute the entropy using the probabilities
and information content.
So we have the probability of A (1/3) times
its associated information content (1.58 bits),
plus the probability of B times its associated
information content, and so on.
The result is 1.626 bits.
This is telling us that a clever encoding
scheme should be able to do better than simply
encoding each symbol using 2 bits to represent
which of the four possible values is next.
Food for thought!
We'll discuss this further in the third section
of this chapter.
So, what is the entropy telling us?
Suppose we have a sequence of data describing
a sequence of values of the random variable
X.
If, on the average, we use less than H(X)
bits to transmit each piece of information
in the sequence, we will not be sending enough
information to resolve the uncertainty about
the values.
In other words, the entropy is a lower bound
on the number of bits we need to transmit.
Getting less than this number of bits wouldn't
be good if the goal was to unambiguously describe
the sequence of values -- we'd have failed
at our job!
On the other hand, if we send, on the average,
more than H(X) bits to describe the sequence
of values, we will not be making the most
effective use of our resources, since the
same information might have been able to be
represented with fewer bits.
This is okay, but perhaps with some insights
we could do better.
Finally, if we send, on the average, exactly
H(X) bits, then we'd have the perfect encoding.
Alas, perfection is, as always, a tough goal,
so most of the time we'll have to settle for
getting close.
In the final set of exercises for this section,
try computing the entropy for various scenarios.s 0*2^11 plus 1*2^10
plus 1*2^9, and so on.
Keeping only the non-zero terms and expanding
the powers-of-two gives us the sum 1024 +
512 + 256 + 128 + 64 + 16 which, expressed
in base-10, sums to the number 2000.
With t3.100
So the information received
is log-base-2 of 2/1,
or a single bit.
This makes sense:
it would take us
one bit to encode which
of the two possibilities
actually happened, say, "1"
for heads and "0" for tails.
Reviewing the example
from the previous slide:
learning that a card drawn
from a fresh deck is a heart
gives us log-base-2 of 52/13,
or 2 bits of information.
Again this makes
sense: it would take us
two bits to encode which
of four possible card suits
had turned up.
Finally consider
what information
we get from rolling two
dice, one red and one green.
Each die has six faces, so there
are 36 possible combinations.
Once we learn the exact
outcome of the roll,
we've received log-base-2
of 36/1 or 5.17 bits
of information.
Hmm.
What do those
fractional bits mean?
Our circuitry will only
deal with whole bits!
So to encode a single outcome,
we'd need to use six bits.
But suppose we wanted to
record the outcome of 10
successive rolls.
At 6 bits per roll, we would
need a total of 60 bits.
What this formula
is telling us is
that we would need
not 60 bits, but only
52 bits to unambiguously
encode the results.
Whether we can come
with an encoding that
achieves this lower bound
is an interesting question,
which we will take up
later in the chapter.
To wrap up, let's return
to our initial example.
Here's table showing the
different choices for the data
received, along
with the probability
of that event and the
computed information content.
We've already talked
about learning
that the card was a heart.
The probability of this event
is 13/52 with an information
content of 2 bits.
Learning that a card is
not the Ace of spades
is quite likely, since
there's only one chance in 52
that it is the Ace of spades.
So we only get a small amount of
information from this event --
.028 bits.
There twelve face
cards in a card deck,
so the probability of
this event is 12/52
and we would receive 2.115 bits.
A bit more information than
learning about the card's suit
since there's slightly
less residual uncertainty.
Finally, we get the most
information when all
uncertainty is eliminated
-- a bit more than 5.7 bits.
The results line up nicely with
our and Mr. Blue's intuition:
the more uncertainty is
resolved, the more information
we have received.
Now try your hand at computing
the information for a few
more examples in the
following exercises.